Speaker 1: All right. Let's debunk some nonsense
claims that are spreading. Always important if
you're going to engage with this stuff to at
least have some sense of what reality is and
understand where the talking points come
from. Now, one of the things that I have
said before is that very often the completely
incorrect, wild, destructive conspiracy theories
from the right have like a kernel of truth
in their origins. Now, I don't mean that the
conspiracy theory itself has an element of truth,
but what I mean is what catalyzed the conspiracy
theory is something that is true. That's like
very generally in the universe of what they're
talking about. And we're going to look at a
clip here of Lara Logan. Lara Logan used to
sort of be a respectable journalist. She has
gone completely off the rails. We've covered
some of her anti-Semitic stuff. We've covered all
of her different conspiracy theories. She seems
completely disconnected from reality, and she
spoke somewhere. You know, who the hell cares?
It's another there's this circle, this speaking
tour circle, where the crazier you, the crazier
the things are that you have to say, the more
likely it is that you'll get more of these gigs.
And Lara Logan claimed that illegal immigrants who
cross the border illegally get a Social Security
number at the border, and that then they can just
go and vote. Now, none of that is true. I will
tell you, after we look at the clip, what is the
likely origin of this? All right. Let's take a.
Speaker 4: Look. Questions, because it's quite
satisfying having all the answers. However, they
they said they couldn't make a decision
at this time or they would let me know.
That's true. But they asked me two very
interesting questions. When I went there,
they asked if I would be willing to take
up arms to defend the Constitution of the
United States of America. Isn't that interesting?
I seem to have forgotten that part. Right.
And then, you know, among the many interesting
parts of this is as you look around you
and, you know, what you have to remember is
that they don't actually believe in citizenship.
Oh. And now when people have crossed the
border illegally and have this confirmed
from Border Patrol agents who are
actually physically doing this,
they get given a Social Security number.
Speaker 1: They get given one.
They get given. That's interesting.
Speaker 4: Right.
Speaker 1: And people in the crowd
go, right. Right. Why would they
get a Social Security number? That doesn't
make any sense. But the crowd. Right. Right.
Speaker 4: They get assigned a Social Security
number when they cross. I'm not sure how many of
you are aware of that. And if.
Speaker 1: You really. Well,
the people aware of it are wrongly aware of it
because it's not true. And we'll get to that.
Speaker 4: When the cheating starts, it's
long before you get to the polls. Right.
I mean, think about it. It starts with the
census, starts counting illegal immigrants in
the census. How do you determine how many members
of Congress you get? Population settings, right.
So how does you know California has all
these delegates and the Electoral College?
Speaker 1: And now, of course, the reason
California has all those electoral votes
is California's population is genuinely
massive. It's bigger than like most countries.
But also the larger your population, at least
in some general sense, the larger number of
undocumented immigrants that might also be.
Speaker 4: There don't just get more money
from the federal government for your increased
population. You don't just get more congressional
candidates representing you. What else do
you get? You get an opportunity to pad the
voter rolls are with people.
Speaker 1: But wait, Lara.
Undocumented immigrants can't vote.
Speaker 4: Who are being completely and utterly
exploited. And there's one thing that I've that
I've learned as I've been investigating this is
they love euphemisms, right? They love euphemisms.
Speaker 1: Sort of like Republicans, right? I
mean, they love to say pro-life, which really
is a euphemism for we tell women what to do.
Speaker 4: Is is it's all about democracy.
And if there's any form of voter security,
that's voter suppression and racism and white
supremacy. And if it's the other side, you know,
anything we can do to get more people out
to vote. I actually when you when you talk
to the canvassers, they'll tell you that
when they go into the low income areas,
you know, sometimes they're predominately
Hispanic, sometimes they're they're white.
But that's where they find the most fraud.
Speaker 1: Fraud. They all the fraud is in
those areas. Now, it may not shock you
that just about everything she's saying
is completely made up. First of all, as far
as fraud or the fraud or fraud or whatever.
It's really it's almost non-existent.
And the couple of dozen cases that we've
actually identified since 2020, it's almost all
Republicans. It's like white Republicans in white
Republican areas either testing the system or like
one guy voted for his wife who disappeared. We
covered that last week. But most importantly, the
stuff about undocumented immigrants are getting
Social Security numbers at the border, which then
allows them to vote. Erin writes. Lynn Melnick
explained the truth about this on Twitter. Aaron's
the policy director for the American Immigration
Council and used to be an immigration lawyer.
Some asylum seekers, he wrote, become eligible
for a work authorization while they wait. Now, it
usually takes about a year. It's not happening at
the border, but there are people who are in the
U.S. illegally. They've been in the U.S. for a
year. They've asked for asylum. They then get
a work authorization and they can get what's
called the restricted Social Security number.
It's so that they can pay taxes and legally
work. And listen to this. They pay into Social
Security. They're not eligible to collect unless
they win asylum and become citizens. So there are
some undocumented immigrants who, after a year,
while waiting for their asylum request to be
adjudicated, have asked for work authorization,
have been told you can do it, but you've got
to pay into Social Security. And if your asylum
request is rejected and you get sent back to your
source country. You don't get anything out of the
Social Security system, essentially subsidizing
the Social Security payments of people who will
ultimately get benefits. That's the truth. They're
not eligible to vote. They can't register to vote.
They would not be able to vote. They don't vote.
They can't vote. So that's the kernel from which
some of these conspiracy theories originate.
Asylum seekers can sometimes eventually get a
restricted Social Security number, and that
becomes at the border. You just show up and
they give you a Social Security number, and
next thing you know, you're voting for Biden.
A complete and total farce. Does Lara Logan
know that she's lying? I think she probably
does. On this particular one, I think that
she probably does. Let me know what you think.